[Music]
two of the favorite terms that I learned
in reading this book are fluency and
disfluency and these terms relate to the
idea that we have feelings about our
thoughts and that sounds hippie-dippie
but some thoughts feel easy it feels
easy to listen to a song for the 50th
time it feels easy to watch a rerun or
easy to read an article that we already
agree with those are fluent thoughts
those are thoughts that feel good and
easy but there are also all sorts of
experiences all sorts of types of
thinking that feel difficult and that's
what we call disfluency so being lost in
a foreign country and trying to figure
out what all of the signs mean that is
disfluent reading an article that is
trying to express a position that you
consider morally abhorrent that is
disfluent too but what's most
fascinating about fluency and as fluency
is how they exist together so imagine
that you're in that foreign country and
you're trying to read all of these signs
and it's in some Slavic language that
you don't speak and you feel lost and
anxious and your your brain is hurting
with all of these sort of thoughts that
are going through it and suddenly you
turn around and you see an old friend
from high school that you immediately
recognize knows that foreign language
that is an aha moment that is a moment
where you transition from disfluent
thinking to fluent thinking and there's
all sorts of studies that have said that
we love these aha moments we love them
in art we love figuring out art we love
them in storytelling we love the
disfluency of not knowing who the
murderer is and then that moment when
ding we got it we know who the murderer
is we even love it I think an ordinary
say a political opinion writing when
someone takes a complex subject and
expresses it in such a beautifully
clarifying way that it's it's like
solving a crossword puzzle for politics
we have click and aha moment they truly
think that people are looking for aha
moments across the cultural landscape I
think that aha moments are a large part
of what we want from storytelling what
we want from a great education what we
want from a great article or a great
book
we are looking
or both fluency and disfluency yielding
to each other so that we can feel those
transition moments that are invigorating
and that make us feel like the act of
thinking is worth it one of the oldest
findings in psychology history is called
the mere-exposure effect and the
mere-exposure effect says that the mere
exposure of any stimulus to you biases
you toward that stimulus so children who
grow up eating more spicy foods tend to
like more spicy foods people who grow up
listen with their parents listening to
more jazz end up liking more jazz
timbers and more jazz styles that we
have a bias toward familiarity and I
think that this is true both for
insignificant tastes like for food and
music and for profound political tastes
there's some evidence that children who
grow up in multicultural neighborhoods
tend to be much less racist or have much
less racial opinions than children who
grow up in more monochromatic
neighborhoods again this is a bias
toward familiarity and I think it's very
important to think about familiarity
bias as a news consumer because there's
lots of evidence that shows that the
mere repetition the mere exposure of
news to to us biases us toward thinking
that that news item is true this is
often how fake news works or how urban
legends can start that you hear the
piece of gossip once and you dismiss it
as mere gossip you hear it twice okay
maybe now it's you know it's it's stuck
in your in your head you hear it from
four different people at four different
times suddenly that gossip becomes truth
because once it becomes fluent once it
becomes memorable you tend to conflate
fluency familiarity and veracity fact
there was a one study that did this is
that essentially looked at this with a
scientific facts they told a bunch of
older and younger people that shark
cartilage was good for arthritis and
they labeled this fact as false for most
the people that they were showing the
fact to and immediately after the study
they asked people is shark cartilage
good for arthritis and both
and all participants said no we know
that it's not good for arthritis that
fact was listed as false when we saw it
in the study but several weeks later
they called back the participants and
they asked them old and young is shark
cartilage good for arthritis the young
participants remembered that the fact
was listed as false but the older
participants who had worse implicit
memory were more likely to say oh well
that sounds familiar
and therefore I think it's true and so
this is one of the big reasons why it's
difficult to myth bust on television or
myth bust in journalism because
sometimes the mere repetition of that
myth biases audiences toward thinking
that it's true because we have a
familiarity bias we cannot help
ourselves from conflating that which is
familiar from that which we think is
more likely to be true face cream Google
absolutely have responsibility to combat
this bias but I don't know what they can
do right now on the technology side I
think that they can hire people they can
hire human beings to go through the news
and figure out what is clearly a hoax
what is clearly propaganda what is
clearly meant merely to inflame and not
to deliver truth and they can ban those
accounts and ban the people who are
responsible for them even though in many
ways that is sort of anathema to
Facebook's fundamental message which is
that we are here to unite the world and
create a global newspaper for all sorts
of opinions and all sorts of content I
think that Facebook has accidentally
become a media company they did not I
think set out to become a media company
but right now for many people they are
clearly the global newspaper and the
largest distributor of information and
content in the history of the world that
is a technology that we've never seen
before and so it introduces problems
that were not familiar with and we're
still grappling with exactly how to
answer them but I do think that
fundamentally the solutions the problem
of fake news on Facebook and other
social media sites comes down to human
ethics it comes down to humans that only
humans can fix this problem we don't
have algorithms that can go through and
separate fact from
and it comes down to ethics the reason
that there's fake news out there is
because there are ethical people who are
essentially attention merchants they are
not journalists they don't want to
demonstrate the truth they don't want to
distribute the truth they want to make
money or they want to inflame people's
emotions and it's difficult to deal with
the problem of lack of ethics with
anything other than a system of ethics
which right now I don't think Facebook
is fully written into its algorithm but
one thing that I think about in thinking
about Facebook's news problem right now
is back to the invention of the penny
press in the early 19th century for a
long time newspapers were expensive at
six pennies apiece and then Benjamin day
comes around and he introduces the idea
of a penny press he cuts the price of
the newspaper from six pennies to one he
amasses this huge readership and then he
sells that readership to advertisers he
invents the dual revenue business model
of news that we still have today that
the Atlantic has the New York Times has
but within a few months of sharing this
newspaper he realized what every other
industry and entertainment has also
realized which is that fiction typically
out sells nonfiction fiction does better
in the movie theaters fiction does
better for books and fiction did better
for Benjamin day when in the 1830s he
introduced a huge moon hoax to the
American audience where he told them
that there were bat men living on the
moon copulating with each other and a
17,000 word feature that got enormous
readership for his penny press newspaper
the solution of that problem the
solution the problem of unethical penny
press newspapers did not come from
Benjamin day it came from the New York
Times it came from an ethical
organization saying we want journalists
from top to bottom who were going to use
this dual revenue business model in
order to sell not hoaxes but news and so
today just as 150 years ago I think that
the answers to a problem of a lack of
human ethics and information markets is
the introduction of more humans and more
ethics into information markets
[Music]